all right Cameron Cameron uh where you
from originally where' you grow up uh
was born in Anchorage
Alaska and lived there for few years
then moved to North Carolina back to
Alaska out of Alaska Minnesota Orange
County La Denver back to LA and now I'm
here and uh tell me about your childhood
your
family my Early Childhood was really
tumultuous
um my mom and dad were high school
sweethearts uh he was Captain wrestling
team she was you know I think voted most
kind or best smile I don't know they
were a couple years
apart and my earliest memories of them
are them
fighting I have a very vivid memory
of my dad Roger having my mom pinned
against the fridge and their fists bany
against each other like drums like and I
know that they probably weren't that
succinct or that structured of hits but
that's how my mind remembers them and I
remember breaking into
tears and screaming for them to
stop and then they did and my dad got in
my face and yelled at the top of his
long stop
crying which is something that uh he did
quite a
bit um and my mom did too in her own way
but never that
intensely then he dragged her in the
bedroom and I heard a bunch of more
noise and then he came out I don't know
how long or later but he picked me up
and I was in the same spot on the floor
crying and I
remember him trying to like console
me
um but I knew knew that moment I didn't
like my
dad I I I
was I was my mom's kid like that's how I
always felt and I I I knew that no
matter what he said in that moment he
couldn't fix that um there was a lot
more fighting and split ups and then
back together and moving out and then
moving back and I mean we must have done
the dance
from um Eagle River Alaska where the
trailer was that we lived in to
I think probably my grandparents house
or my mom's friend's house multiple
times finally she left
him uh she got
custody he had visitation
rights um and it was me and my mom we
were on welfare she was working her ass
off to like put food on the
table but I never felt in need of or a
lack of you know my mom mom came from a
childhood where she was the last of nine
to very dysfunctional alcoholic addict
parents and
siblings and the one thing she wanted to
make sure of when she had a kid was that
they always felt safe and nurtured and
cared for and loved and that's what she
did even when we were
broke um were you only child yes at that
point yes um in fact I am my mom's only
child she ever gave birth to um and I'm
the oldest and the only boy we we when
my mom remarried my
stepdad not remarried when she married
my
stepdad he did have a daughter who was
much much older going into
college so we had that like brother
sister Dynamic but it was never really
easy or comfortable she had a lot of
feelings around um our father and her
mother getting divorced
you know uh rightfully so and then it
was just me my stepdad David and my mom
uh for many many years I hated him at
first I thought he smelled bad I was the
man of the house I was in charge who the
is this but uh some point he won me
over I think mostly because I saw how
much my mom loved
him and I wanted my mom to be happy
but you know I went in and out of some
pretty severe depressions around that
time you know we
moved we moved to North Carolina after
he proposed so that he could continue to
go to school he's he was a
doctor um he was becoming a more
specialized kind of doctor he wanted to
do high-risk terminal pregnancies he
wanted to really like be there and
like make a difference in these women's
lives
um I remember the wedding I remember
moving to North Carolina I don't
remember you know feeling particularly
happy to be there I don't
remember I don't remember going into my
first depression and for many years I
didn't remember the sexual assault that
happened at that time in my life nor did
I
um understand that my mother's
um bipolar uh was kind of coming into
full swing you know there would be times
when mom was gone visiting my aunt and
you know I had my stepdad just trying
his best to go be in school to be you
know a resident to be a doctor and me
being in a new state with no friends and
trying to
manage um but yeah it wasn't a
particularly happy time I also was
unable to read or write at that point in
my life um I was severely behind in
school which didn't help with the
teasing it didn't help with feeling
different then you know I already felt
effeminate and not like other boys my
age and didn't get along with a lot of
my peers no matter where I was at um so
not being able to read and write also
made it
worse you know it's it's
having the means
to like like having my dad my stepdad
who was a very educated man have the
means to look at me and witness that
there was something different about me
and instead of shaming me for it or
making me feel worse helping me figure
out what it was um we did some tests and
I was I was uh diagnosed with um some
severe learning differences and luckily
uh we got me the right tutoring and the
stuff I needed to be able to actually
learn to read and process
information um so I feel very grateful
for that but at that time in my life I
was diagnosed in addition to being
dyslexic and um have an auditory deficit
disorder I was diagnosed with bipolar
depression anxiety and add and they put
me on like
intense pharmaceutical meds to like
manage all
that
um I was just a kid you know I I I look
back on
it and I wonder
like did it help me did it not help me
I've had these diagnoses taken back so
many times and then given to me so many
times especially um in and out of my uh
relapse
Cycles
um you know once we got out of North
Carolina um I also started gaining a lot
of weight I became pretty obese as a
child um my height kept like shooting me
up so but then my my um food intake
would you know catch up to my height and
it was just kind of this really intense
cycle of you
know not uh being able to feel good in
my body um you know I
remember we moved back to
Alaska and I was going to school and I
was I was happier I was happier at this
point I don't know if it was cuz I was
back in Alaska or if because you know at
that point my mom had gotten on meds and
my dad was no longer in school he was
working it just felt more structured and
safe um but I remember feeling
happier but in school again I was having
social issues um if I was wasn't be
being called Gay I was being called fat
um I remember like learning at this
point in my life that the best way to
combat like not being liked was to make
sure you liked me by giving you
something um and you know whether it was
me demeaning myself and making fun of
myself or me getting my mom to bring
McDonald's to the class or me giving you
my toys or whatever it was was I needed
you to like me I needed to feel safe in
whatever situation I was and I equated
safety with the validation of people
liking
me
um uh at this time in my life I you know
I've had some weird moments sexually as
a kid as as a child is it the sexual
assault that you talked about well it
started you know the first thing I
remember
is being
um two or
three and this is the first time I
remember sexually I was I was basically
playing Mommy and Daddy with a girl from
my preschool like she came over we were
having a play date I fully initiated us
getting completely naked and playing
Mommy and Daddy in my bedroom and my mom
walking in at some point horrified
absolutely horrified and like separating
us and of course that little girl could
never come over again and you
know my mom is not one to shame me for
things but she was she was definitely
very very disturbed and rightfully so I
mean I don't know what I would what I
would think if I walked in on my kid
doing that but to me it seemed normal at
that age I also initiated things with my
cousins um and I never knew why you know
I never I never you know you hear that
old adage like oh kids experiment kids
you know explore their bodies and I I do
think that's true but I had almost like
a weird Obsession around it um many
years later I
um through some uh brain spotting uh
therapy that I was getting at a rehab I
was
at um I had this memory come back and
I'd always had the core memory I I had
this preschool teacher named Mr
derky and he was like
God to me like I idolized this man um
and I just remember one day randomly him
taking me to his apartment and putting
me in his room on his bed and handing me
this stuffed seal toy plushy that like I
I had that thing forever I loved that
toy and that's all I remembered for
years and I never thought anything weird
of it always just assumed my mom knew
about it um it wasn't until later in
therapy and talking with her that she
she was like I would never let you go
like I don't know why you would have
been there um and then through you know
trauma therapy which is really been a
lifesaver for me uh I remembered I
remembered what happened um and it's a
weird experience to go from having just
like one core memory of something and
like weird feeling inclinations of
something and then having your mind
fully reveal it I I I I I've doubted
myself at times um um but I know that
the feeling I feel in my body when I
when I uncovered this memory and when I
process it and think about it I know
that feeling isn't made up that feeling
is real um and it was by no means the
severe sexual trauma that happened to me
later but it was still inappropriate and
um you know it was inappropriate it was
a lot of inappropriate exposure to me as
a small child at that Agee between me
and my preschool
teacher and so I think that's why I've
gotten I I became fascinated with the
body at that age um and started
initiating those things the the the
severe sexual assault that happened um
when I
was
seven that I uh you know I I completely
had blocked out
um
so in North Carolina we lived in this
apartment complex and there you know
again socially I was not super Popular
by any means um but there was a group of
of brothers that uh I played with
occasionally and they had like a sister
and they were like our next door
neighbor and so like we you know like
neighbors make their kids play together
and there was these woods behind the
complex and I remember us all going out
there several times and there was like a
a rope swing and it was kind of like our
Fort but I have this memory and I had it
forever of me and the older brother
going into the woods
alone and then I had the next memory
after that is just me coming out and
again like I never thought anything of
it
um until last summer uh I was in rehab
again for like the 24th time um and I
was doing EMDR which is a type of trauma
therapy that helps you reprocess traumas
that are held in your body and I was in
one memory about something else and then
all of a
sudden I was there in the woods the boy
was right there the older brother was
right there it was like I was like
reliving the whole thing and I was being
forced on the ground and brutally
assaulted
uh and I was raped that
day I completely disassociated from it
um blocked it out you
know I do
find I do find it interesting though
simply because if I look at my path as a
sexual being and I look at my path as an
addict and I look at the traumas from my
childhood I clearly see the correlation
between all of them the number of times
I've put myself in dangerous sexual
scenarios high on death um that were
violent
aggressive um
dangerous it's too numerous to
count and I think it was like my
subconscious way of trying to process
what had happened as a child before
knowing before my conscious mind knowing
that any of that had
happened I've been using crystal
meth let's see here you know in 2009
uh I tried it for the first time and
then my uh my stepfather was hit and
killed by a
car
um and that became a coping thing for me
for a while escaping into like crystal
meth I would I would I would use for a
few days come out not touch it for a
while try to show up for my mom who was
completely devastated and like imploding
from the pain of losing the man she
considered her her soulmate dealing with
my uh adopted sisters um we had three in
the marriage between my stepdad and my
mom they adopted three different uh
girls two of which are blood
sisters um they got them at different
times and then my friend Jordan who I
went to high school with needed a place
to live and we brought her
in um but yeah you know my my dad dying
uh David my my stepfather dying you know
it's not just like a doctor dying it's
not just a husband dying it's not just a
father dying or a brother
dying it's like our whole family died
everything that I knew to be our family
unit and our structure of living was
shattered and I didn't know how to cope
you know and I had done this
substance that gave me relief from all
the that I had buried my whole life
and gave me a way to escape and express
myself and so between trying to pick my
mom up off the floor keep my sister safe
and manage my own internal going to
Crystal Meth was a welcomed escape and
it's something that happened
semi-regularly
for I mean since
2009 um sometimes the relapses would
last longer than others
sometimes it would be a night and then
you know I wouldn't do it and I always I
always ended up going back to trying to
be sober always trying to go back to
like my family always trying to go back
to some semblance of like what it means
to be Cameron you know I I I have this
tendency to live as I think everyone
does but to live in this world of Black
and Whites and so it's like
when I'm when I use crystal meth when I
shoot crystal meth when I'm having chemx
when I'm doing these things it allows me
to live in this Darkness void of any
light and it's a darkness that I get so
scared of touching and so scared of
being consumed by that when I get sober
inevitably I always know I'm going to
get sober because for me I am not the
type of drug addict that can function
using crystal meth I throw out my job I
throw out my relationships I throw out
any semblance of a life so that I can
have sex and be high and
um so when I get sober and I I see that
light inside of me come back on and I
and people are noticing it and I'm
feeling healthy again all I want to do
is push that Darkness away because it
scares me so
much it scares me so much
um and I
think living in
that crazy ju toos is one of the things
that have perpetuated my my drug cycle
for so long um you know
I I'm currently
at I honestly don't know what number it
is you know last time I counted up the
number of rehabs and programs I'd been
to it was in the 20s and I know that
sounds really
nonchalant but at some point
I just I just I kind of have to have
this attitude of like well at least I
keep trying you know uh cuz some people
don't they either give up completely or
they die or they don't get the
opportunities that I have gotten and the
grace that I've been given by my loved
ones by
God by the universe like not everyone
has the chances I have had and I
recognize that um but yeah I mean I I've
been to tons of treatment centers
I successfully completed most of them
but none of them went past like 4550
days um I tried a few long-term
treatment programs that were that were
focused on behavioral
modification things that like you know
involve shaving your head and making you
carry a toilet seat around your neck uh
Squat and cough you know wearing scrubs
not being able to talk then putting you
in a room and yelling at you about what
a piece of you
are and like that's that's not what
makes me want to be
sober so you know the times I tried to
do those
programs I I left pretty quickly I I
tried to go to one of those in Hawaii
they made me close my bank account they
made me leave my cell phone and get on a
plane and they picked me up and 3 days
later cuz I I knew like I knew the I
Knew by the way that I just was being
treated in 72 hours that it was not for
me and I had to beg them beg them to let
me call my mom so I could go home and my
mom didn't believe me she thought I was
full of but they dropped me off at
the Honolulu airport with no money no
phone no ticket and I had to like
survive and figure a way to get home you
know I had
whatever I mean my point in all of that
is I've tried
everything and I've done 12 step and
I've done
therapy and that demon that is crystal
meth and IV use and sex continues to
haunt me
um you know I I
have
almost 5 months over I just got four
months about two and a half weeks
ago
um I'm in a program
currently um that I won't mention the
name of but it's a long-term program
and its focus is around community and
spirituality and reigniting your
passions and discovering who you are
um you know I I think one of the big
things that I've struggled with you know
especially coming from a background
where my my birtha was so dogmatic and
so just
insanely like religious to the point
where like when my mom divorced him he
tried to give us an
exorcism you know um I I think I've kind
of had this knowing of God this
understanding of God a belief in God
especially as I got older and found my
own concept of God but I've never had
faith in God you know I've never
believed fully that you
know God would have my back or that I
could be sober by putting my life into
God's
hands but something's been happening you
know in this new experience and in this
new recovery where I keep getting
tested by
situations and
uh I just keep choosing to trust the
process and stay and I'm feeling really
hopeful I haven't felt hopeful in a long
time that's great
yeah so you are a drag queen you you
became a drag queen at what
age um so I so Co hit and I was in a
sober living and i' been laid off from
my job
and I I just decided you know that I was
going to take the
Curiosity and the desire to learn drag
and put it into action I had all this
free time and a place to do it that felt
safe and so in 2020 Summer of 2020 I
started practicing my makeup and
then um by November of that year I moved
to Denver I I decided I wanted to get
out of La everywhere I looked I saw my
crystal meth addiction everywhere I
looked I saw like just really painful
memories and I picked Denver uh because
it reminded me of in my home state
Alaska uh and had a better queer scene
than Anchorage
did um and I went and by
February spring of 2021 I had managed to
get myself a job as a part-time drag
queen at one of the local bars and
bartending there and you know I just I
put every ounce of creative power I had
into it for the last three
years so it's been a journey uh I love
it it's one aspect of who I am and I uh
I will continue to do it the rest of my
life because it it gives me a way to
express myself and be a
Storyteller and it also bring brings joy
to people's
lives
um and ultimately like connecting with
people and making them smile is
important to me and and getting to be
fabulous while doing it why not
so what age were you when you discovered
that drag was something that you were
interested in being a
drag I would say like my earliest memory
of putting on feminine clothing and
playing make believe I would have been
about seven six I was living in North
Carolina with my family and I just
there's this dress my mom had it was
like this crushed velvet uh maroon
colored dress and one of those like '90s
Blossom bucket hats and I would just
like run around the garage and like hop
over things pretending I was like this
super secret agent spy but like like a I
don't know I just idolized like powerful
feminine women and that was the make
believe that was the
fantasy um and then I did theater I grew
up doing plays and you know that was
really my outlet at first I was a really
awkward uh overweight
shy uh confused young child and finding
theater finding the ability to express
myself save my
life um so in theater I think the first
time I did drag I was in a play called
the road to Kyoto it was a kabuki Style
Show and I was playing a monk but one of
the gishes dropped out of the show and
like and all my 10-year-old Glory was
like I'll do it and so I did and then
after that I went to performing to Arts
High School at one point and uh we did a
showcase where I played Edna from
Hairspray and I remember like them
giving me the costume and me thinking
this is not enough like this is this is
not this is not fabulous enough but you
know I didn't really know how to make it
better so I just
actually stuffed the bra with some
grapefruit and did my best to like
embody uh Harvey fire Stein and sell it
for what with what they were giving me
um and then I would say drag drag like
this concept of drag that we have today
I mean really I owe discovering it to
drag race and Rupa and all of that um
and of course like exploring gay bars in
my early 20s and seeing them out and
about they always just fascinated me and
that was definitely the first time I was
like I want to do that to that level but
what I mean for some men they're
attracted to Big Dynamic women like
yourself but you want to be one I what
do you think that that is that you want
to be one rather than just so hang
around them so for me it's not that I
want to be a woman um you know I
remember at a very young age I told my
mother I think I was about
three feeling very different and feeling
out of place with male peers and male
adults and telling my mom I feel like a
girl trapped in a boy's body now like in
the concept of uh transitioning today
and the and you know what it means to be
trans and be in the wrong body uh I
could see how looking at that you know
three-year-old self saying that you know
that that could potentially be my story
but really for
me it's not that I want to be a
woman it's that I feel and honor the
feminine femininity within me as well as
the masculinity within me you know it's
a both and for me I'm not one or the
other uh my soul is both male and female
um I identify as gender
fluid but this particular uh expression
of Cameron is known as 11 Divine I am a
professional drag queen and for me I've
modeled my drag off of my mother and
like classic famous pop culture female
icons and 90s super
models and I don't know I've just I was
raised by women I was always loved by
women better than I was by men and it
just comes from this deep place of
respect and liking to feel beautiful and
wanting to be every Pop Star Diva
fantasy I ever had as a
child but I I don't want to necessarily
be an actual woman and that is confusing
for some people I I I've been in plenty
of scenarios dressed up like
this um where I flirt and I play and
it's after after a club gig and you know
back when I was drinking you know maybe
I was a little tipsy or you know they
were definitely Tipsy but you know it
never got to a point for me where I was
like yes I'm going to go home with these
people and and let this be their fantasy
um I've definitely taken people home
from the bar in full drag but it always
comes off because I'm I feel blessed to
have come to a place in my life where
the physical form I was born with I feel
comfortable in and that was isn't always
the
case is this something you do outside of
your performances dressing up as a woman
I'll practice it um but no I I don't
first of all this takes a long
time uh much much longer than I would
like it to and also much longer than
would deem necessary to go to like the
grocery store
um that being said in terms of like the
traditional cultural like definitions of
that is something a man would wear that
is something a woman would wear I don't
really um subscribe to uh if I want to
wear women's clothing to the extent that
like oh that's a brand of women's jeans
or that's a shirt for a woman or that's
a dress that I altered and made into a
tunic for for me like I don't care about
any of that um but no like I don't go
out my dayto day or go on dates or go sh
in in in 11 Divine uh
clothing and so you are gay or straight
or by that's been a really long uh Road
of self-discovery I'm what I uh describe
or refer to as Demi pansexual so for me
first and foremost I have to have an
intimate connection to the person like I
they don't need to be my soulmate by any
means but for me to feel especially
sober you know for me to feel safe and
comfortable enough to explore myself
sexually with someone and be aroused and
like ejaculate and and really like be in
the moment I have to have some level of
intimacy with them otherwise I get
triggered so I no longer really uh
participate in random casual hookups I
don't use the traditional like gay apps
um simply for my safety for my recovery
and as well because I've just discovered
that like that type of uh intimate
pleasure leaves me feeling worse about
myself and I and it's in no judgment to
other people like everyone's different
but my goal is to stop hurting myself
with drugs and I find that when I have
that kind of sex I just want to hurt
myself with
drugs
um so Demi and then pansexual meaning
that for me it's about the person I
don't care what's between your legs I
mean don't get me
wrong I want what's between your legs
but it's not the defining aspect of my
attraction for
someone um and that's confusing for a
lot of people um especially when it's
paired with your drag
queen and your gender fluid so again the
question is like do you want to be a
woman do you not want to be a woman they
never know how to put me in a box and
Define me I feel really fortunate to be
at a place in my life and gone through
enough self-discovery to know who I am
and to be okay with people not getting
it and we're also in a really cool I
would say Renaissance Era of gender and
pronouns and
sexuality um which is fabulous a and
it's a kind of a weird timing
because um of the level of push back
some of it's getting but that being said
I think
these these types of people these gos
this like concept of self-expression has
always been there in a lot of us we just
haven't had the words to describe it yet
or felt safe enough and so I'm really
happy that we're at that place do you
have any regrets do do you regret not
coming out sooner or so I do have
regrets
um you know I I
actually my whole life I was told I was
gay you know it's interesting to think
about kind of the narrative that's in
some parts of the country and world
where this concept of like queer culture
drag queens trans
people parents with trans kids you know
trying to indoctrinate or you know raise
kids to be
gay because the truth of the matter is
is I'm not
gay and my whole life I was told I was
gay by people that weren't in the
community weren't safe adults for me I I
mean if it wasn't my peers it was their
parents if it wasn't teachers it was the
principal I I once took unicorns to show
Andel and I was going to this like small
uh private Catholic preschool in
Anchorage
Alaska
um and I got in trouble and put in
the he wasn't the principal and I don't
think he was he was like the dean or
something the Degan I don't know I'm not
religious but I got put in the office
and over her them calling my father who
wasn't in the picture saying your son's
gay he's going to infect the other
children we need you to come handle this
and then I found out later that my dad
took my mom to court again over me
because of this
so I have always known that I was
different people told me I was different
I felt
different um and so when it became a
thing about like discovering my body and
my
teens you know it was coming from a
place of like some intense sexual trauma
as a child that I was unaware of I had
um disassociated and blocked it out um
an immense pressure to like be gay
because that's what I was thought I was
and also this deep fear that I was gay
because I I Associated being gay with
people going to like make fun of me or
or belittle me because that's always how
it sounded when I was told I was gay oh
you're gay oh you're gay he's gay so it
was just a really convoluted Concept in
my mind but uh you know at
I definitely started having those
physical urges and it was right around
that time that um AOL had popped up and
you know you give a at that point we're
living in Minnesota you give some
confused little little queer boy uh
access to the internet they're gonna
find they're gonna find trouble and I
did and it's uh it was behavior that led
me all through my teens into my early
adult years which eventually led me to
Crystal Meth how did your family handle
all of this so you know my biological
father who really wasn't in the picture
he was more of like
um I don't know it was like an
obligatory
like role right like he gave the seen he
you know he was there when she gave
birth but the truth is he was never
really a father to me um we would try to
pretend that he was but ultimately my
father was my stepfather um my mom met
him when she was his ultrasound
technician in Providence Hospital in
Anchorage Alaska and they had this wild
Affair and fell in love and he became my
dad and he he always loved me for me uh
I feel really blessed about that but you
know like I said it was always a thing
Cameron's gay Cameron's gay so you know
uh the first person I had consensual sex
with was my best
friend and we gotten really
stoned and it was just it was like that
really cheesy like we started tickling
each other and the next thing I know
other things are happening and then you
know we go to bed we wake up he leaves
to go back home and I go downstairs to
my parents who are having coffee and
reading the paper I'm like Mom Dad you
know how I've been wondering if I'm gay
and they're like mhm like well me and
stevenh had sex last night and I hated
it so I'm definitely not gay and the
response was you know my dad basically
took pulled his paper down out of his
face and was like just be safe we love
you and my mom said just give me
grandchildren I love you um so it was
all always just love from them which is
fortunate because socially outside of my
family that wasn't the case and from my
biological father it was always we're
praying for your salvation we're praying
for Cameron's Soul
um you know uh you were born this this
way well yeah you know it's that's an
interesting question it's like the
chicken or the egg you know are we born
gay is it is it nurture is it
nature I don't know if I have the answer
for that so so the sexual abuse you went
through when you were a young boy MH do
you think that played a role in in all
of
this I think like any traumatic
experience that someone
survives it can't not play a part in who
they become you know for me my first
Addiction ever was
fantasy then food and my mother's
love
and so yeah do I think that you know
being brutally raped in the woods next
to our apartment building in North
Carolina led to me putting on my
mother's dress and being a top secret
agent spy in the in the garage yeah I do
because it made me feel powerful and it
helped me
escape I don't feel
like like because it was with a a guy
who did that to me and because I do have
sex with men that that's why I do drag
exclusively but I I do think there's a
correlation there much like how I can
see that the confusing time you know of
like my first love and losing my
virginity you know to my best friend and
AOL and then him like
disappearing on me and like icing me out
and me not having an outlet to turn to
turned me into like looking for things
online which all snowballed into my
addiction later in life everything's
connected and tell me about your journey
with with drugs my very first experience
with like being high was with Stephen
you know know before we ever had
sex again like socially I wasn't very
cool and he just thought I was cool like
I had been having trouble in school and
kept starting new schools because of it
and when I ended up at the uh at the
elementary or middle school he was at I
was doing these anime characters and
drawing them and I drew him and his
skater friends as little anime cartoons
and that got me in the door and then
eventually I got an invite to his house
and we smoked pot and so drugs for
me have always been a way to
connect they helped me get out of myself
and out of my
discomfort and you know being high and
being stoned is definitely connected to
the first time I had
sex you know and so as a young
adolescent exploring their body confused
about their sexuality going in and out
of the closet you know having the
habitual like tendency to find me older
men online like I'm talking like dads
and minivans picking me up and having
sex with me in the middle of the night
um it was like an inevitable point in
time that I would end up doing harder
drugs you know at first
um my first hard drug really uh so I
graduated high school in 2005 I got into
a private university in New York City
for uh theater and writing and I went
there and I picked up a cocaine pain
addiction and I didn't go back after
Christmas break instead I got my friends
heavily addicted to cocaine and we went
on a really hard Bender for almost a
year until one of us ended up going to
rehab and you know we told our parents
and you know I remember sitting in cars
at like 4:00 a.m. like coked out of my
mind thinking it was the worst thing in
the entire world and like having this
feeling of just total Despair and
disgust at
myself and I have more recent memories
of living in my
car High out of my mind on crystal meth
shooting up for
days and being back in that feeling of
the cocaine internally like that disgust
and turmoil and wishing it had just been
cocaine I had been doing at this point
um it's been almost two decades of binge
using IV crystal meth you know the first
time I ever did it was
in I think 2008
2009 I had met someone on um good old
Craigslist he offered me
ecstasy and I went to his house in
Glendale and he gave me the Ecstasy and
once I started rolling he whipped out
the the meth pipe and a little bottle of
GHB and my defenses were
down
um I actually blacked out and came to in
his kitchen being very obscene and him
asking me to leave at like 4:00 a.m. but
I was hooked you know at that point like
the Beast had been
awoken
um meth
made all the years of sneaking around
sexually not feel like
wrong and it allowed me to have the kind
of
uninhibited wild sexual
fantasies that almost mirrored the
traumatic experiences of my childhood
but in a way that gave me some sense of
control right like you know I'm putting
myself in the situation and it's okay
because it's fun and hot but when really
it's it's not okay for me it wasn't you
know um I left his house in Glendale and
found someone next to my apartment
building using and went to that person's
apartment and did it for a couple days
didn't touch it for a few
months and it just became a Perpetual
cycle in my
life I was always honest with my mom
about it was hard to hide it from her
and my best
friends
um it's it's been a really rough Journey
tell me what happens emotionally with
this this ride you're
on when I'm high it it emotionally
it's it's like I know the emotions are
there because I'm a I am I'm a very
emotional centered human being I I I can
confidently say that my ability to be
intuitive about other people's emotions
and my own and process them is really
high but when I'm high I can just shut
it off and shut it away at least I used
to be able
to um now coming down from that high
processing the the the things I had done
the people I had let down the things I
had missed that were important to
me I
just I've been on the floor in a like
heaping pile of just depression so many
times suicidal from
it just completely devastated and
lost and
hopeless
I I know what hopelessness feels
like and uh it's it's one of the
worst places to be
internally um and it's even worse when
your external surroundings match that
internal
feeling
would you say you're misunderstood by
most
people yeah I would for a variety of
reasons you know for
me I have to constantly tell people I'm
not
gay which is ridiculous you know I get
it yes I'm a drag
queen and yes out of drag I can have
some more flamboyant Tendencies
sometimes
but like people I I've known like I know
that like I live around work around hang
around they'll just be like oh you're
all gay well I'm I'm not and it wouldn't
be a big deal to me except that it's
like if I don't correct them it's a it's
a narrative that will continue like it
has my whole life to play
out um it affects you know I feel I feel
misunderstood by a lot of women I try to
date I get friend-zoned a lot um I feel
misunderstood by gay men I try to
date uh I've literally been in
situations when I was using especially
where like I'm doing my best to play
like the masculine side of Cameron and
you know I've got the leather and the
jockstrap and the high top socks and
sneakers and a backwards baseball cap
and I'm like yeah yeah yeah like
whatever and then because I'm human and
I can't lock every part of who I am away
at every second of the day and I've been
with these fools for like almost 24 48
hours because when you're doing meth
like you're not going anywhere um and I
let something slip or like I'm trying to
show them a picture and they see my drag
or whatever and I've literally watched
like them go from he's so hot to
wait she's a drag wait she like you uh
and then they're not attracted to me
anymore when two seconds prior to them
knowing this bit of information about me
I was hot to
them which really just speaks to their
own internalized homophobia and their
own but that being said you know I
used to do crystal
meth to
feel sexy and have this fantasy and some
like make up some semblance of who I was
because I didn't know who I was now at
37 years
old through everything I've been through
I have a better understanding of who I
am and so when I relapse you know in the
recent like past two years when I've
relapsed and I try to put myself back in
this box for these
people I can't do it it suffocates me um
so yeah I feel
misunderstood by the tweet Community I
feel misunderstood by the sober
Community because I am such a chronic
relapser I I get a lot of love from them
too don't get me wrong like you know I
am not a
quitter in both ways you know it's like
I can't seem to quit the drugs but I'm
also not quitting trying to get sober um
and that tenacity that I I have to like
better my life I know they see and
respect that but yeah being labeled a
chronic relapser and sort of like you
know the time game when when are they
going to relapse again that feels like
being
misunderstood um I feel misunderstood
when it comes to my
pronouns um which you know for me in
drag she her that whatever um out
of drag for me it's they them he him he
her like for me because I believe my
soul is all encompassing as long as you
come at me with respect we're good um
not everyone gets that some people in
the queer and in the trans and in the
non-binary community don't get that they
think I I have to
decide you know I remember working at a
gay bar in Denver you know I I had just
started doing drag professionally I was
bartending behind the behind the bar and
so it was such a dichotomy right like
you know one night I'm on stage like
flipping my hair and grinding on you
know gays for cat cash and then the next
night I'm behind the bar shirtless with
a cowboy hat
on and I remember talking to a another
local Entertainer who identified as TR
who identifies as trans and talking
about a local Show and her going oh but
it's for Trans and non-binary people
only and granted I was presenting very
masculine at that moment but like I
looked at her and I was like I I
actually identify as gender fluid uh you
know is it something I could do and I
saw her face go from this is a cute boy
to who does this person think they are
trying to like identify when they
clearly look a certain
way granted those words never came out
of her mouth and as a good alcoholic I
probably overanalyzed all of that but
that's how I
felt so I I felt misunderstood most of
my life even by
myself what would you say is your
greatest
strength
well I'm
definitely
persistent
I I would say my greatest
strength is my ability to see the good
in
people my ability to offer love and
Trust to people I don't know it's gotten
me in a lot of up
situations but I would rather come at
this world with a loving open
heart then let any of the trauma I've
experienced any of the stuff I've gone
through shut that heart
down I believe we're on this planet to
love each other learn to give and
receive love and like just be in Harmony
and it I know I know it's like a stupid
utopian thought that feels almost
impossible especially with what's
happening all over the world right
now
but to me my capacity to love is my
greatest gift
um and like I said you know I'm a
Survivor I'm a fighter I'm going to keep
pushing for my dreams and goals I know
exactly what I want to do who I want to
be who I am and what I'm capable
of and I used to have this story in my
head that I was
lazy I've let other people's stories
about my talents that they're not enough
or not good enough get to me sometimes
I've let other people's opinions other
people's successes other people's
failures dictate and control my
perception of myself and what I think
and know I'm capable
of
and I feel like I'm at a point in my
life where I'm done doing
that you
know do do you have friends do I have
friends I have yes I have friends I have
a very small group of friends that I've
had a long time that's all you need yeah
um I've learned that if I feel like I'm
watering the garden too much and the
plants aren't growing I'm going to get
out of the
garden I don't like feeling used
and I don't I don't need to do that like
you either want to be in my life you
either love me or at least respect and
like me enough to put effort into
something or you don't and that's okay
we don't have to like
everyone I you know I'm not everyone's
cup of tea and that's
okay you're still young yet but do you
fear getting
old yes I do you know um I mean yeah I'm
young like I know it's all relative
right it's all perspective I'm 37 I feel
like I was 6 years old yesterday like
it's it's crazy how fast it
flies especially when I compare it to
like before crystal meth like after
Crystal math you know High School
College before my dad died after my dad
died it's just
like when it's broken into these periods
of time and I look
back on how quickly it went by and also
how long it's actually been especially
when it comes to my using
I was in a rehab last summer and we were
like counting up our like years of use
and I was
like and then it hit me i' been I've
been doing crystal meth for 18
years 18 years did you feel like you
wasted those
years or did you have a lot of
fun was there fun
yes but I'll say this you know one thing
that I have to remind myself cuz cuz
it's not fun anymore it's one what what
they're putting in crystal meth now is
not the crystal meth I was doing 10
years ago it's not it's killing people
um and it's also affecting the brain
differently you know they they actually
are changing the process in the way in
which they make the meth now so that it
makes you crazier faster and it's more
addictive and it was already addictive
to begin with um so like now I can be
completely like one of the relapses I
had earlier this year I was Stone Cold
Sober for maybe 2 months and working a
program and then made the dumb choice to
relapse went to the person's house put
it in my
veins and I I instantly instantly I mean
I felt the shift right I put something
in my body but I just knew like it's
not it's not working anymore and whether
it's because the drugs are bad now or
whether it's because I've got almost 20
years of 12ep and rehab and therapy
chirping in my brain or whether it's
because I've come to a place about who I
am
internally and how I want to Value
myself externally whatever the reason is
the drugs don't work anymore I get you
know I've never been someone that's like
you know is someone out there is that a
is that the FBI oh my God that
helicopter oh shadow people it's never
been it's never been my
jam but my psychosis my crazy is they
don't want you here you're not good
enough to be here they think you're
weird and it's just my voice telling me
all these very hurtful hateful things
about the situation I'm
in and then me getting of course
externally weird and awkward and being
like do you guys not want me here which
you know it's just it it's just a
horrible Perpetual cycle of of
self internalized
destruction all right Divine 11 11
Divine 11 Divine spell with two L's
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you and I wish you lots of
luck